le problème il est qu'il n'est pas
capable de descendre et d'aller voir sa
tribune et de leur dire de se taire ou
est au moins d'accord là-dessus non non
raciale manquent pas mais comme vous
n'avez pas de courage vous non plus vous
serez pas descendu ans donc c'est pas le
problème vous êtes l'ap2 vous êtes de la
même manière c'est à dire que quand on
met le pantalon le matin il faut pas
oublier certaines choses là dans la
chambre à coucher il faut coucher tous
mettent dedans
monsieur verneiges
vous savez quand vous parle je pense que
gilles pote mon style
voilà le truc donc à partir de ce moment
là déjà la première fois il avait dit
que c'était la faute de payet qui
prenaient des trucs dans la gueule
c'était sa faute c'est il s'était rendu
ridicule là il n'a rien dit il ils ont
envoyé un communiqué landes il n'a rien
dit pas un mot rien les supporters se
sont excusés
à l'école sans latendresse qui a débuté
chez castanet je m'excusais
usa les belles séquences de il s'excuse
vous êtes d'accord quand d'autres
personnes c'est ce que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord vous est à géométrie variable
rosa bon marché il fait pas bon marché
devant vous dans la cendre a pendant le
vol
gilles par les soupes et les objets non
mais c'est vous alliez un tant soit peu
de temps en temps dans les stades vous
verriez corrosive hôtel 60 ans et où il
ya longtemps que les supporters pour
encourager leur équipe et c'est pas le
faux pas d'un petit groupe qui doit
faire qu'on s'acharne sur l'ensemble des
gens qui vont au stade c'est le peuple
qui va au stade ils ont commis un faux
pas ils se sont excusés mais les absout
vous êtes de parti-pris vous acharnez
sur nice je suis sans doute qu'ils n'ont
pas non non vous embaucher comme vous
rendez pas vous faire un succès mais
voilà
un mail à ces jeux
n'ont jamais perdu je sais que j'ai
jamais rempli un cv jamais une lettre de
motivation on est toujours jamais bossé
les joueurs c'est m
[Applaudissements]
alors vive la syrie agent de joueurs de
mélodies
toujours hui n'est que moi j'ai toi ça
va
alors viennent pas taper les pompes sur
les roses d'accord soit 10 retire-toi
ans ils
seront trente secondes gmail hervé vas
tu t'énerves et toi t'as pas buter
taillé dans un casque de bal musette
[Applaudissements]
pas vous
bon là
[Applaudissements]
quant à lui en cas d'une seule fois
avec tous
à
[Applaudissements]
jet tours n'a plus rien
ce ration déluge sur les clubs
c'est indigne
[Applaudissements]
je me suis amusé à venir ici parce que
j'ai vu que tu fais une belle pomme de
terre
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai rien à dire on voit ça fait
cinquante ans que suis dans le milieu du
foot se feraient sentir bien à dire du
monde
[Applaudissements]
j'en avais toi j'ai dit moi je charge et
j'ai fait moins d'erreurs que la
rigolote
lui dans la phase i tahiti c'est
monsieur favard pas
s'il te plaît si toi tu es déjà pas mort
et spa pauline moi
c'est sur ce fondement
résultat
[Applaudissements]
les
[ __ ] du nord
[Rires]
non mais je vais lui dire alors j'aime
beaucoup l'île voilà comment ça vous
avez
oui oui incroyable vous l'avez dit
regardez j'adore j'adore ce qu'il fait
mais il est là une fois tous les six
mois les bénévoles tendre et blé à
chaque match on n'en veut plus il est
alors moi je l'adoré mais aussi j'aime
bien barroso
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi j c est autour de nous emmerder
qui t'a valu une exclusion juppé très la
gueule moi
[Musique]
com